GREG: TALK ABOUT PUTTING STUFF
IN PERSPECTIVE DO YOU REMEMBER
WHAT WAS GOING ON LAST WEEK WHEN
ASKED 2020 WITH THE IS UP WITH
YOU?
YOU WANT TO ONE UP 13 WITH A
BLACK PLAGUE AND YOU WANT TO
MAKE 1933 OR 1918 APPEAR QUAINT
BUT PLEASE WE BEG OF YOU CAN YOU
CUT US A BREAK FOR A FEW DAYS
PLEASE?
WE GET IT YOU ARE THE WORST.
WE WILL MAKE YOU AT CHUCK RAVI
WORST YEAR EVER OKAY?
AS YOU ARTINO ARE TO KNOW THE
PRESIDENT FIRST LADY TESTED
POSITIVE FOR THE CORONAVIRUS.
OUR THOUGHTS ARE WITH THEM AND
EVERYONE BATTLING THE VIRUS AS
WE ASKED FOR A SPEEDY RECOVERY.
NEWS CHIEF OF STAFF MARK MEADOWS
FRIDAY.
>> WE ADDRESS THIS BATTLE
TOGETHER AS A NATION TOGETHER
AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE CAN REST
ASSURED THAT WE HAVE A PRESIDENT
THAT IS NOT ONLY ON THE JOB AND
WILL REMAIN ON THE JOB INCHER
FASHION AND HE’S PROBABLY
CRITIQUING THE WAY I’M ANSWERING
THESE QUESTIONS.
GREG: YOU ARE RIGHT, HE IS.
THE PRESIDENT REMAINS ON THE JOB
AND QUARANTINED THAT THE
ELECTION IS A MONTH AWAY AND
THIS WILL NO DOUBT THE IMPACT
THE WEEK AHEAD.
HOW WILL IT AFFECT THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL AND WHAT ABOUT THAN THE
NEXT DEBATE ON THE SUPREME
COURT?
I DON’T CARE THAT MUCH.
THERE’S MORE THAN ENOUGH TIME TO
TALK ABOUT THAT AND BELIEVE ME
WE WILL AT FIRST WE HOPE FOR THE
BEST FOR PRESIDENT HIS WIFE IN
OUR COUNTRY AND HERE’S MY
SUGGESTIONS TO WHETHER THIS
LATEST NEWS.
STAY OFF SOCIAL MEDIA PLEASE
BECAUSE WE KNOW EVERYTHING
TODAY’S POLITICAL AND WORSEN THE
SARA PEOPLE WHO DISAGREE WITH
YOU THANKS TO THE MEDIA SEE YOU
IS EVIL.
THEY WILL TAKE LEGEND IS NEWS.
IRONIC PEOPLE WHO HAVE EMPATHY
HAVE NONE IN THEIR BACK PACK AND
EVEN SO-CALLED CIVIL BOLDFACE
NAMES ARE MORPHING INTO KIDDIE
POOLS.
IF ANYONE SAYS SOMETHING TO YOU
THAT YOU FIND IN BAD TASTE DON’T
REACT COULD SIMPLY SAY THIS, CAN
WE TRY TO PUT ASIDE THIS
PARTISANSHIP AS THEIR PRESIDENT
FIRST LADY ARE FIGHTING A
POTENTIALLY DEADLY DISEASE?
LET’S TRY TO BE AMERICANS AND
NOT REPUBLICANS OR DEMOCRATS FOR
A DAY OR TWO BECAUSE THE STATE